[Musique]
que
si céline roblin 46 ans j'habite à
montigny-le-bretonneux et donc j'ai
décidé d'ouvrir siphonner du bocal qui
sera une épicerie vrac zéro déchet donc
début octobre 2021 ici est vrai un
bretonneux
[Musique]
la plupart des produits seront donc sans
emballage donc servir en bocaux en silo
avec vos propres contenants ou bien sûr
je vous en propose ray et il y aura
aussi quelques produits on va après
emballé mais avec l'ocde des emballages
consignes et principalement et puis des
produits français locaux le plus
possible
c'est une reconversion professionnelle
j'ai travaillé 25 ans dans
l'événementiel donc j'ai organisé
principalement des réceptions de mariage
et l'événementiel donc a été touché par
la crise sanitaire du coc vide donc j'ai
réfléchi et ce secteur d'activité marc
m'a plu puisque moi-même voilà j'ai opté
pour une démarche zéro déchet dans ma
vie
pour créer l'entreprise effectivement il
ya une partie de l'apport personnel inde
après un prêt bancaire et j'ai obtenu
donc après un prêt d'honneur via via la
région en 50 en yvelines pour le
financement j'avais aussi lancé une
campagne de financement participatif ça
m'a permis de pouvoir acheter batoul et
les silos que vous voyez là au départ ce
n'était pas forcément prévu puisque
c'est un beau budget en fait ça m'a
permis de le faire
le bout pour moi c'est vraiment de deux
d'être assez accessible que ses produits
sont accessibles et de voile à favoriser
l'achat en vrac le plus possible pour
qu'on puisse réduire au maximum ses
déchets
[Musique]
peut-on